[Musique]
la soupe de tomate kembo et la première
soupe en conserve commercialisé en
amérique du nord en 1897
je pense pour tout le monde quand on
pense souvent
sopo tomates en particulier un mot une
couleur qui nous viennent en tête c'est
rouge et ses cannes beau 123 ans plus
tard la célèbre soupe est toujours là
mais elle est loin d'être seul sur les
tablettes j'aime pas ta soupe
on a une belle à bout méli mélo puis
jean vit dans une certaine confusion
dans tout ça
la chef et aux tris caroline dumas est
bien connue pour sa grande expertise
dans le monde des soupes
elle nous explique la différence entre
ce potage velouté et crème une soupe si
les morceaux avec un bouillon un
bouillon clair un potage ce serait un
légume broyer une carotte un potage de
carottes puis on aurait un velouté
ensuite donc les volutes et lui il va
hyper passé dans un chinois
la crème et moi pour moi la crème un
conte et de la crème donc une crème de
tomate normalement il devrait y avoir la
crainte les soupes potages ou crèmes
sont des produits qui ne sont pas
normalisées il n'y a donc pas de règles
de composition imposées à l'industrie
ironiquement il n'est donc pas
obligatoire qu'une crème de légumes
contiennent de la crème en principe à
tout - en termes de textures et tout ça
on devrait répliquer ce qu une crèmerie
l'essentiel des échantillons qu'on va
regarder aujourd'hui contiennent quand
mamie la crème mais certains produits
portent l'appellation crème et ne
contiennent ni crème ni substances
laitières notamment la gamme de produits
imagine qu'ils sont volontairement sans
produits laitiers on a un produit aussi
du côté de commençal où ils ont choisi
de remplacer la crème classique ou
traditionnelles par de la crème de coco
les ventes d'aliments en conserve comme
les soupes sont à la baisse depuis
plusieurs années tandis que l'offre des
soupes réfrigérée s'est grandement
développé les entreprises se permettent
de nous surprendre avec des mélanges
d'ingrédients qui sont très gourmands et
des épices particulière des fois on
voyage davantage quand on est dans le
frais que quand on est dans la concerne
les soupe en conserve se vendent sous
deux formats le plus répandu étant le
condensé
elles ont été évacuées et concentrés en
fait comme le nom l'indiqué pour entrer
dans un plus petit volume
mais sachez que ça se consomme pas tel
quel il faut le diluer avec son
équivalent soit d'eau de lait 1 -
mélange des deux comme on voudra toutes
les entreprises en fait il nous offre
ces soupes leur propose en priorité non
pas de consommer la soupe qu'on lancé
comme une soupe mais comme un ingrédient
à utiliser dans une recette
les prix varient beaucoup dans cette
catégorie de produits passant de 29
cents à environ 1 dollar 50 par portion
de 250 millilitres
et quand on voit dans le frais sans
surprise c'est plus dispendieux on est
autour d'eux et 30 à 2 dollars 80 la
portion ça s'explique où ça se justifie
notamment par la qualité des ingrédients
et la proportion d'ingrédients frais qui
est à l'intérieur
isabelle a procédé à l'analyse
nutritionnelle des 43 produits que nous
avons retenue dans différentes
catégories
déshydraté en sachet condensé en
conserve et des produits prêts à servir
en conserve en contenant longue
conservation et réfrigérer toute l'offre
qui est réfrigérée qui dénonce ou peu
fraîche
les compositions sont beaucoup plus 5
plaît beaucoup beaucoup moins d'additifs
que ce qu'on retrouve de façon générale
dans les autres conditionnement tetra
pak ou si même chose composition très
très simple on est vraiment très près de
ce que ça aurait l'air si on le faisait
soi même à la maison
ce type de produits est depuis toujours
reconnu comme étant très salée
visiblement il ya un effort qui est fait
est une intention qui est le pour
réduire la teneur en sodium
malgré tout ça reste que bon on aime sa
saleen on est habitués de manger salé et
pour plusieurs entreprises
malheureusement elles ont dû revenir
complètement la case départ quand même
remonter le sel qu'ils avaient diminué
parce que les consommateurs n'aient mais
pôle produits une fois réduits en sodium
résultat on passe de 3 190 mg à 900 mg
par portion surprise il y à du sucre
dans nos échantillons jusqu'à 16 g dans
ces deux produits kembo soit
l'équivalent de 4 cuillères à thé en ce
qui a trait aux matières grasses
rien à signaler d'inquiétant dans
l'ensemble on n'a pas de dangereux
vraiment de matières grasses malgré
qu'on parle de crime les toners sont
assez faibles alors quoi de y'a pas de
souci là-dessus mais y en a trois qui
vraiment sort du lot les junkies poulet
à la king et crémeuse poulet et nouilles
et la classique kembo crème de
champignons dans sa version prête à
manger toutes les trois contiennent
entre 20 et 35 % des matières grasses
qu'on devrait consommer au maximum dans
une journée
aucun des produits analysés ne peut être
considéré comme un repas puisque la
teneur en protéines est insuffisante
les teneurs en protéines aussi entre 1
et 3 grammes ce qui est très très peu
donc à moins d'ajouter soi même de la
viande un oeuf ou autre chose dedans
pour l'enrichir telle quelle il y en a
aucun voici les meilleurs choix parmi
les 43 produits pour moi c'est la
première réponse simple quand on est
dans le frais et dans le réfrigérer
c'est plus intéressant
côté composition je vous le disais
beaucoup beaucoup moins d'additifs on
est très proche de ce que ce serait si
on l'avait cuisine et nous mêmes la
marque imagine nous offre une gamme de
crèmes sont produits les tic qui est
très intéressante en qualité composition
en valeur de trith y vivent aussi et ce
sont les seuls produits de tous les
échantillons qui sont biologiques
maintenant si on veut quand même rester
dans la conserve de façon générale je
dirais tournée vous si vous pouvez vers
les versions qui sont réduites en scène
elles sont encore très c'est les flux et
d'autant plus si vous aimez agrémenter
votre site avec des craquelins du
fromage et tous à la saveur vont être là
vous serez pas déçus
et comme c'est souvent le cas rien ne
bat un potage fait maison avec beaucoup
d'amour potagers garaient hyper simple
caramélisation des oignons encore des
morceaux de carottes les carottes les
légumes bio les carottes sont légaux mis
par pau cher piller vraiment différence
[Musique]